Welcome.
My name is Samuel Nixon Jr., an
alum of the MIT Gospel Choir.
Did you know that
Black students at MIT
have traditionally
relied on faith and music
for spiritual sustenance
through the academic and social
pressures of life
at the Institute?
Yeah.
The MIT Gospel Choir is a
half century year old example
of this tradition and
meaningful reliance.
And from its early
formation in 1971 by others,
this body of
faithful students has
grown from the informal original
group of 10 undergraduates who
quote, unquote, "simply
enjoyed singing to each other,"
according to the then president
and co-director Ricardo Hall,
"to a more formal and
amazing group of songsters,
all walks of life."
Choir members have been singing
traditional gospel, hymns,
and spirituals for around five
decades in local churches,
in the Christian Fellowship
services at the MIT Chapel
and all around the
Boston/Cambridge area
and beyond.
Today, during this holy season,
a segment of the MIT Gospel
Choir alums from
across the years,
I'm privileged to present to
you just a few moments of joy
and celebration of some of the
historic journey of this legacy
choir.
Won't you pause with us now to
remember some of the singing
fellowship and exciting
moments of sharing the gospel
and song in this special
MIT Gospel Choir holiday
presentation?
It's our joy to share with
you with each musical note
and chord amidst the hustle
and bustle of the season.
Yeah, we know.
We know.
Come, relax, and spend
a few moments with us
as you hear the
sweetness of song,
the melodies of
memorable moments,
and voices of faith expressed
during our student years.
Yes, even around the
corridors of the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology.
Welcome.
[MUSIC - RICHARD SMALLWOOD,
"HOLY, HOLY, HOLY"]
(SINGING) Holy.
All right now, sing my song.
Holy.
Lord God.
Almighty.
Holy.
Lord God.
Almighty.
Heaven and earth are
full of Thy glory.
All heaven and earth
are full of Thy glory.
Lord, Holy and
righteous is Your name.
Omnipotent, Glorious,
Holy is Your name.
Holy.
Welcome the MIT Gospel Choir.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - HEZEKIAH WALKER, "HOLD
OUT"]
I'm going to hold out, gonna
hold out 'til He comes.
God has just begun to make
a way, make a way for me.
I'm going to hold out, gonna
hold out 'til He comes.
God has just begun to make
a way, make a way, way.
Storm clouds may arise.
Strong winds may blow.
But I know the Lord will
take me through it all.
He'll make a way, way.
Stormy clouds may rise.
Strong winds may blow.
But I know the Lord will
take me through it all.
He'll make a way,
make a way for me.
I'm going to hold out, gonna
hold out 'til He comes.
God has just begun to make
a way, make a way for me.
I'm going to hold out, gonna
hold out 'til He comes.
God has just begun
to make a way, way.
Storm clouds may arise.
Strong winds may blow.
But I know the Lord will
take me through it all.
He'll make a way, way.
Storm clouds may rise.
Strong winds may blow.
But I know the Lord will
take me through it all.
He'll make a way,
make a way for me.
I'm going to hold
out, gonna hold out--
Hi.
My name is Mae White Wesson.
I was a member of the
MIT class of 1975.
And I graduated with
a degree in Course 7.
I was a member of the MIT
Gospel Choir from its inception
until my graduation.
I joined the choir
because I love to sing.
I had always been a
member of whatever choir
was age appropriate for
me from my childhood
until my graduation.
I enjoyed being in the
choir, sharing time
with other Black
students at MIT.
Because at that time,
there were not many of us.
My class had 25 or
47 Black students
in a class of about 1,000.
So it was quite a culture shock.
I had not gone to
an integrated school
before my appearance
in Cambridge.
So participating in the choir
gave me a sense of continuity.
It gave me a system of support.
It gave me time
spent in something
that I was familiar with.
I think the importance
of the choir
was that it showed that
MIT was changing a bit.
There was some
attempt at diversity,
at least as far as adding
Black students to the ranks.
I think we made a big
impression on the campus
and also in the greater
Boston/Cambridge community.
We had concerts.
We had programs.
We sang in the Great Hall.
It was a joyous
time and experience.
Hello, this is Michael Dixon.
I was at MIT from 1984 to 1988.
And I was a bass in the Gospel
Choir, sometimes a tenor,
and they forced me to.
I just wanted to
explain why the Gospel
Choir was so near and dear to my
heart during that time in MIT.
It was also one of the
best support activities
that I was able to be a part
of and I had a privilege
to participate in.
There are a lot
of great friends,
a lot of great challenges
that we face together.
And those things have
impacted me to this day.
As far as memories go, I want
to just remember the times
that we sang in Kresge with
the New Jersey Mass Choir.
There was an awesome poster
along with that concert.
That was the one that
was very colorful.
It was just a blessing to
be a part of that piece.
I remember the
times that we were
able to connect with people
like Philips Bryant, who
sang Going Up Yonder.
It's one of those songs we
always used to love to sing.
She was our Aretha Franklin.
She was a powerful voice.
I also remember singing
some original song
from Daryl Gaskin, Daryl
"The Roof Is On Fire" Gaskin.
I remember singing Psalms
150, I'm Saved by Grace.
One of my favorites
was 2,000 Years Ago.
Awesome.
We sang some more original
songs from Tyrone Williams.
Remember having Easter service
at Kresge with St. Paul's
A.M.E. And I remember being
able to go into the organ
and hear it play at Kresge.
I remember doing a tour.
We went to tour the East Coast.
It was a blessing.
But one of the years we did
tour was during the Challenger
explosion, where
we lost Ron McNair
and a few other astronauts.
Ron McNair was an MIT physics
major and grad school.
And he was known by
many of the people.
We were actually going to visit.
So it was a really solemn time.
We also sang Let
Mount Zion Rejoice.
And we dedicated that
song during the tour.
But also, we sang
it, the dedication
of the building, Ron
McNair building as well.
I remember connecting with
people such as my wife, Crystal
Dixon, who it was a
pleasure to work with
and to be able to interact
with and so many other people.
It was just an awesome thing.
But some people stick out.
For example, China Altman, who
was just a courageous woman who
was part of the media at MIT.
And she's the one who helped
us get those posters done
amongst other things.
But she was just a blessing.
And just to see how she was a
benefit to us, and we, I think,
impacted her as well.
[MUSIC - CURTIS MAYFIELD,
"PEOPLE GET READY"]
(SINGING) People get ready
for the train a coming.
Don't need no ticket.
You just get on board.
All you need is faith to
hear diesel's humming.
No don't no baggage.
You just thank the Lord.
People get ready for
the train to Jordan,
picking up passengers
from coast to coast.
Faith is the key.
Open the doors and board them.
Don't need no ticket.
You just get on board.
There ain't no room for
the hopeless sinner.
He's got to save mankind
just to save his own.
Have pity on those for
the chances grow thinner.
There's no hiding place
from the Savior's throne.
Ah, ah.
People get ready for
your time grows shorter.
You better get ready
before the train is gone.
And there'll be no time to
get your house in order.
Live every day and
just thank the Lord.
So people get ready
for the train a coming.
Don't need no ticket.
You just thank the Lord.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - KIRK FRANKLIN, "THE
NIGHT THAT CHRIST WAS BORN"]
(SINGING) The night
that Christ was born.
Oh.
Ah.
The night that Christ was born.
Listen to angels
rejoicing ever so sweetly.
Receiving Heaven's glory the
night that Christ was born.
Can't you see the people coming
from every nation pleading
for salvation the night
that Christ was born?
Listen to the angels
rejoicing ever so sweetly.
Receiving Heaven's glory the
night that Christ was born.
Can't you see the people coming
from every nation pleading
for salvation the night
that Christ was born?
Oh, such a wonderful Savior
to be born in a manger
so that I can share His favor
and my heart be made anew.
Listen to the trumpets.
Won't you listen?
Shouting through the darkness.
Crying holy, holy the
night that Christ was born.
Oh--
Let's have a warm welcome
for the MIT Gospel Choir.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - EDWIN HAWKINS, "TO MY
FATHER'S HOUSE"]
(SINGING) Come and go with
me to my Father's house,
to my Father's house.
Come and go with me
to my Father's house,
to my Father's house.
There'll be no crying there.
There'll be no dying there.
Come and go with me
to my Father's house,
to my Father's house.
Come and go with me
to my Father's house,
to my Father's house.
Come and go with me
to my Father's house,
to my Father's house.
There'll be no crying there.
There'll be no dying there.
Come and go with me
to my Father's house,
to my Father's house.
In my Father's house,
there are mansions there.
If it were not true, I
would have told you so.
I want to prepare
a place for you.
Now I know you can
come there too.
Come and go with me
to my Father's house,
to my Father's house.
Oh.
Come and go with me
to my Father's house,
to my Father's house.
Come and go with me
to my Father's house,
to my Father's house.
There'll be no crying there.
There'll be no dying there.
Come and go with me
to my Father's house,
to my Father's house.
Yes, in my Father's house,
there are many mansions there.
If it were not true, I
would have told you so.
I want to prepare
a place for you.
Now I know you can
come there too.
Come on and go with me
to my Father's house,
to my Father's house.
Oh yeah.
Come and go with me
to my Father's house,
to my Father's house.
Come and go with me
to my Father's house,
to my Father's house.
There'll be no crying there.
There'll be no dying there.
In my Father's house, there
are many mansions there.
If it were not true, I
would have told you so.
Come and go with me
to my Father's house,
to my Father's house.
Come and go with me
to my Father's house,
to my Father's house.
Come and go with me.
Come and go with me
to my Father's house,
to my Father's house.
There'll be no crying there.
There'll be no dying there.
In my Father's house,
in my Father's house,
there are many mansions.
There are many mansions there.
If it were not true,
if it were not true,
I would have told you so.
Come on and go with me.
Come and go with me
to my Father's house,
to my Father's house.
Come on and go.
Oh, come with me.
Come on and go with me.
Go with me.
Come on and, come on and,
come on and go with me.
Hey.
Go with me.
There'll be no crying there.
There'll be no dying there.
Go with me.
Come on and go with me.
Well, go with me.
Go with me.
Come on and go with
me come on and--
hey.
Come and go with me
to my Father's house,
to my Father's house.
There'll be no crying there.
Come and go with me
to my Father's house,
to my Father's house.
Come on and go with me.
Come and go with me
to my Father's house,
to my Father's house.
[APPLAUSE]
I was contacted sometime
during the summer
preceding my freshman
year by a student
at MIT, Georgette
Redmond, who was also
from Ohio, Toledo, Ohio.
And she called to contact me.
And we shared some information
about our mutual interest
in singing.
I was elated to find out that
there was such an organization.
But it turned out to be
extremely important to me.
Later that same
summer, I tragically
lost my younger brother.
And the choir was a
huge part of the support
that I received while
grieving, but also needing
to maintain my
studies and maintain
most importantly, my faith.
I think we impacted
MIT and the community
by demonstrating our faith,
adding a different perspective
to the faith community at
MIT from an African-American
perspective and an artistic
perspective as well.
How did I come to participate
in the MIT Gospel Choir?
Well, I had a couple
of friends approach me.
And one at a time,
they were like, Sean,
we'd like you to
join a gospel choir.
I said, I'm Catholic.
We don't really
do gospel choirs.
I'm not sure.
I'm already in the
Catholic community.
Didn't know who would be
a conflict of interest.
And thirdly, I
really can't sing.
And one by one, they each said
that those were not issues.
There were not conflicts.
And I said, I'd give it a try.
And I'm glad they persisted,
because I really enjoyed it.
It was great to see so many
people from different walks
of life, from the
North to South,
from the urban settings,
the rural settings,
different denominations
get together and just
praise the Lord together.
The experience was great,
especially in a very high
stress environment.
It was always time well spent
when I went to the practices
with the MIT Gospel Choir.
One day, I invited my
parents and my brother
down to see us perform.
It was the first time
we had a full band.
We had a couple
guitarists, organists.
And I didn't tell
them that I was
going to be conducting a
couple of songs with the choir.
Turned out really well.
Totally surprised them.
I think my brother even asked
if I had switched religions,
which I didn't.
But it was very memorable.
And I'm glad they came.
[MUSIC - TRADITIONAL, "O COME, O
COME EMMANUEL"]
(SINGING) O come,
O come Emmanuel.
And ransom captive Israel
that mourns in lonely exile
here until the Son
of God appears.
Rejoice, rejoice,
rejoice, rejoice, Emmanuel
shall come to thee, O Israel.
[MUSIC - CHRIS TOMLIN, "HOW
GREAT IS OUR GOD"]
(SINGING) How great is our God?
Sing with me, how
great is our God?
All will see how great,
how great is our God?
How great is our God?
Sing with me, how
great is our God?
All will see how great,
how great is our God?
Hi, I'm Cheryll Gill.
I joined the MIT Gospel
Choir in the fall of 1988,
which was my freshman year.
I was happy to join
the choir, because it
was a continuation of
my experiences in church
and community choir
since my youth.
I really appreciated
the fellowship time
with the Gospel Choir.
We encouraged each other as we
practiced songs in rehearsal.
And I count several
lifelong friendships
among the choir members.
Our choir engagements were
also an outreach ministry.
I recall singing at college
Sundays at the Massachusetts
Avenue Baptist Church in
Cambridge and other area
colleges.
But I think my favorite
memory was the spring 1989
concert with Candace
Buckner singing
God Is to a large audience
in Kresge Auditorium.
Our concerts gave
us an opportunity
to reach people who didn't
come from a faith tradition.
[MUSIC - TYE TRIBBETT,
"HALLELUJAH TO YOUR NAME"]
(SINGING) Lord, You
are good and your mercy
endureth forever and ever.
Your power is greater
than anything.
Because of Your grace I have
life everlasting and more
abundantly.
Lord, you mean everything.
Lord, and I worship
You most high.
And I'll bless Your name O God.
For You are worthy of
the highest praise.
Hallelujah to Your name.
Thank you for taking
the time to share
in this inaugural
special presentation
by the MIT Gospel Choir alums
during the holiday season
of 2022.
We hope that you found it
enriching, encouraging,
and even exciting as we reveal
just a glimpse of the history
of over a half a century that
this organization has been
offering songs of hope and help
and healing to a hurting world.
The MIT Gospel
Choir is a witness
of what has been
a significant part
of our life-changing
experiences while engaged
in our academic studies at MIT.
As you've just heard
and experienced
in the music, testimonials,
and songs of just a few
of the alums in
our group, you can
tell that this organization
has been a blessing to many,
not just those in
the MIT community,
but also across the
greater Boston/Cambridge
area and even the Eastern
coast of the United States.
We are grateful to
have made a difference
in the lives of the
people whom we've
touched through song and
witness and our service
to our community.
And we'd like to
give Thanks to those
who have taken the
time, such as yourself,
to hear our voices speak to
the value of the relationships
and the fellowship that we've
experienced in our faith
journeys.
Many have passed our way and
still have very fond memories
of the bonds and
lifelong relationships
that were fostered through
the MIT Gospel Choir
as it grew and developed
over the years.
There is much more to
come as we look forward
to presenting more of the
joyful and revealing ways
that the MIT Gospel
Choir has impacted
the communities of MIT
Boston/Cambridge and the East
Coast.
Stay tuned for our 2023
series of presentations
that will be offered through
the activities of the Black
Alumni of MIT, also known BAMIT,
and the MIT Alumni Association.
It's an exciting time for
reunion for our choir.
And we invite you to be
a special part of it.
If you would more
information, you
can contact Mae White
Wesson at maewesson@aol.com.
That's spelled M-A-E
W-E-S-S-O-N at aol.com.
Or you can also contact Samuel
Nixon Jr. at snixonj2@aol.com.
That's spelled S N-I-X-O-N
J the number 2 at aol.com.
We will also be
releasing announcements
through the BAMIT and
MIT Alumni networks
over the course of 2023.
On behalf of the MIT
Gospel Choir alums,
we hope you have a great rest
of your 2022 holiday experience
as you reflect with us on
the songs and the testimonies
you've heard.
We look forward to you
joining us again in 2023.
Blessings to you and your
family in this holy season.
This has been a production of
the MIT Gospel Choir alums.